Steve before you set out to make a film
do you ask yourself what will the
audience for this film want or is that
something that it's not really a
filmmakers job to ask that question you
know I think it all depends on the story
in the case of Crime and Punishment this
was a story I felt that really begged of
this idea of bearing witness and because
I really felt like early on that if we
couldn't bring the viewer as close to
the these moments that the officers were
living through and talking about and
really trying to shed light on that you
know they might not people might not
believe these claims so you know that's
where this great gift of observational
filmmaking really can unlock
storytelling because of this idea that
if you really stick around long enough
you gain access to very unexpected kinds
of moments and also the layers of truth
start to kind of like really reveal
themselves whereas I can the beginning
you may be seeing sort of moments that
speak on in like an issue level that
might have interested you early on by
the end of filming it you know the the
process the relationship with the
subjects that you're filming all of that
kind of gets so intimate that you are
inadvertently over a series of years you
know presented with a very kind of human
character driven kind of access and and
that's that's really where I think that
the the kernel of storytelling really
happens like where you get to truly know
people on a very intimate level so
looking at your IMDB it looks like your
first directing credit was in 2003 and
then you didn't have another directing
credit until 2012
what challenges were you facing that
kept you from creating anything during
that time so
yeah it's a really good question I I
think one of the biggest challenges in
filmmaking is just simply having the
confidence to continue pushing forward
when you have an idea or a project you
know I had a lot of false starts between
during that span of time but what really
was important to me during those years
was actually having the opportunity to
work on other people's films and so I
always felt like it was important if I
was going to direct my own work to
understand - kind of like master in my
own practice how to shoot for people how
to edit for people and by way of that
really you know be able to inform my own
directing one day with these kinds of
like not just technical skills but real
very different kinds of language when
deeply engaged in the filmmaking process
you know that I was think back to you
know what I'll Maysles used to say which
is like half of directing is the
cinematography and half of directing is
the editing and you know for that reason
he would give Charlotte swearin
co-directing credit when she would edit
their films just because of the
multitude of infinite decisions that go
into crafting a film on the editorial
side so um I really am glad that I had
this opportunity to work in other
people's films and at the same time it
really motivated me to feel like you
know after a certain number of years I
was really ready to really dig in on my
own work you did an interview about your
2012 documentary which is high tech low
life which I would love to see by the
way I watched the trailer and I watched
interviews looks excellent and you said
that you didn't want to over dramatize
the stories of these citizen journalists
and I'm wondering how how is that that
sort of over dramatization and how did
you do that with the NYPD 12 officers
for crime and punishment
sure
you know I think like when you you think
like linguistically about storytelling
right there's this idea that we have
these tools of empathy building and
rhetoric that at our disposal and it's
easy to get carried away or find that
the narrative you construct is rooted in
this kind of like a rhetorical argument
of built around character development or
this idea of like the creation of
empathy in people's stories and their
experiences and and I think that we have
to be very careful about how we use
those those tools because the they are
simply just tools and we have to have
kind of a more thoughtful endgame in
mind you know for the Kate in the case
of high tech low life I didn't want to
over dramatize this inherently dramatic
story because of the political
conditions within which they were you
know doing their work so these are
citizen journalists who are traveling
across mainland China reporting
uncensored news and also trying to
disseminate this idea that individuals
all carry possess a kind of social
capital that if activated collectively
there could be a very powerful kind of
like sea change in the culture around
what can and can't be said in the media
and in social media and that there was
more room for freedom speech that then
people realized and so in that idea was
for me this notion that if we dramatized
the notion of like a Western view of
China and kind of like the draconian
landscape that everybody you know
political landscape that everybody likes
to portray China with you know it would
be in service of kind of like a more
riveting film but I think it would not
be faithful to the reality on the ground
which is you know these guys were
representing a real gray area and
an expansive gray area of political and
free speech and so that was a really
kind of important lesson to me that you
know I wanted to make sure that the the
tone and the use of dramatic cinematic
language was always you know thoughtful
and kind of like commensurate to the
real truly honest political kind of
condition at hand in the case of crime
and punishment I think that this idea of
you know building character right from a
story perspective these are obviously
real people so to call them the
characters and subjects is always a
little discomforting but the sake of the
conversation you know building character
was very important right if you can't
have a human connection to these
whistleblower officers in the film then
you would never release yourself to kind
of imagine this the highest-stakes
nature of what they're doing and the the
real kind of like social and political
impact of of everything that they're
putting on the line to try and expose
but that being said this could not this
couldn't be rooted and simply any single
characters dramatic story arc because
the the larger goal for me in this film
was to create something that had a sort
of systemic view that incorporated many
officers that we were meeting and not
just that but kind of like had a story
structure that would lead from one
person to the next to the next so that
there was a kind of corroborating effect
in the storytelling in a sense you know
for me that was perhaps like a less
dramatic kind of strategy to take as far
as you know what would have been so
potent to just tell head when Raymond
story or just sandy Gonzalez's story but
ultimately I think it was in service of
this
kind of more important goal that I
recognized
we need to insulate the project with
which is with this different kind of
story structure that was moving back
back and forth between sort of a macro
sort of systemic view and then the micro
human view on the ground literally
suggested through these aerial drone
shots right of the precincts if you see
the film there we could we can get at
something both structural in terms of
the policy that hat was having a
discriminatory impact in minority
communities and also make sure that the
viewer was grounded in like the real
human stakes of people living through
these systemic issues and then also
additionally insulate the film so that
it's much harder for the department to
dismantle any singular narrative or say
you know this was kind of like you know
the this is a like the the claims of a
disgruntled cop or you know every
precinct has its bad apples that will
have something negative to say about the
department so I don't know if that
answers your question but there was a
lot that kind of went into the the story
I heard you say in another interview
where I read something that you did not
want the weight of the film to rest on
just one story and so I'm wondering how
did you make sure that you divided the
time so that it's not so in so sort of
fault or or that it's it's not just a
film about one sort of story with the
food minor one's inner woven right yeah
I mean there I was really sensitive to
this idea that you know when you push
back against an institution right as
these officers in the film are doing
that often is the case that you know
people will say oh well this is one
disgruntled cop or this is one bad apple
everyone every department has a bad
apple and this kind of like bad apples
idea was something I was very sensitive
to and wanted to make sure that
we created a story structure that was
rooted in kind of a more nonlinear multi
character mosaic which we could create a
corroborating effect so that one officer
story would dovetail into another would
lead us to another would then be you
know introducing a some lawyers who are
working with a private investigator that
lead us to the community with young
people who have been are arrested
multiple times for falsified charges and
so on and so forth so that there was
this true kind of ecosystem of criminal
justice or a systemic truly systemic
view of what was happening in New York
City that would be much harder to refute
or dismiss if then if it was a single
character narrative that we were putting
a lot of pressure onto and so I think in
a lot of ways the the burden of this of
the film's message could really be
spread out by many and shared by all I
think you said too for an interview you
did with the Sundance Institute that you
believe that there's no financial
incentive to draw the documentary
process out past a year but obviously
this took what four years to make crime
and punishment yes so I'm wondering how
are you able to put in four years of
time and not run out or did you run out
of money several times and you were able
to apply for grants yeah I mean I think
you know most people working in
nonfiction are finding themselves in
situations they're shooting for years in
order to prove to funders that you know
they have a credible story or a kind of
like a proof of concept on hand you hear
many times you submit to you know grant
applications you know and or to funders
and you know they'll say well come back
when you have more this looks really
interesting and to the point where you
know people want rough cuts of work and
so it's it's it's it's really a
difficult path to try and finish an
independent documentary you know because
you're expending a lot your personal
savings or resources your everybody is
crew
or most people are occurring tremendous
amounts of personal debt on credit cards
and whatnot
and so you know it's it's very hard to
justify but yet you know when you feel
like you are finding yourself in the
crux of a very kind of perhaps
never-before-seen story or access to
individuals that have not you know had
their stories told and it's that's a
very kind of compelling reason to just
find any way possible to continue
shooting so you know luckily I think
being able to freelance in film for
other projects is you know was a
thankfully a way to kind of sustain
myself you know when times were tight
and then ultimately you you know then
ultimately I was able to get funding
thankfully from some really amazing
organizations and individuals you think
of most documentary filmmakers deal with
maybe a reluctant subject you said
earlier the chance for them to tell
their story were there are times when it
was too much too fast because they were
so relieved that you were here you were
ready to listen they were ready they
were at a time in their lives where they
knew they were gonna do this take this
leave and you had to slow them down yeah
I mean is really overwhelming moment
once you know the class action was
formed they were you know you know since
12 cops who were part of this class not
all 12 of them wanted to be filmed but
the majority of them did and so that was
about 10 officers it including
individuals who were sort of on the
receiving end of you know certain
discriminatory policing claims and the
lawyers and a private investigator and
community community members so there was
definitely a span of a couple years
where I was felt like I was constantly
on call and always overwhelmed with
wanting to follow like a very
multifaceted
narrative that had a kind of nonlinear
structure to it but feeling like it was
almost nearly impossible to be
everywhere at once what wound up
happening that was really kind of
helpful for me was I realized you know I
could only dig in to what I could dig
into at any one given time so if I spent
like a week or two with one individual
it was actually a good thing to have
time away from somebody else you know it
would allow the story to advance there
would be you know a renewed vigor and
excitement to film and you know I think
it was it was a good thing to not always
be in everybody's face but that said you
know it was a tremendous amount of
filming because I was like very
interested in wanting to find the story
organically and find the structure
organically and you know be responsive
to what was unfolding over the years and
so I'm sure there were times when of
those 12 maybe they weren't sure they
wanted to go through with it maybe not
well were there ever times when you
questioned your motives or your ability
to withstand sort of taking on this
giant yeah I mean I think you're you're
not making a film if you don't feel at a
certain point like a tremendous amount
of uncertainty and self-doubt and
question the very motivation of what
you're doing right I mean you you can't
ever fully know that you're taking all
these people who have put their story
and their truth and trust in faith in
you that you're gonna actually have
something to show for that and so it's
an incredibly stressful burden and
responsibility that you know and certain
points you that line is blurry like
where are you doing this for yourself
are you trying to doing this to
ultimately make sure that you can
deliver on a promise and and that's a
very that's a tricky situation because
we can't be making films for our
subjects but yet we certainly don't want
to let them down because they've
instilled so much faith in us and
so I think that ultimately you go
through so many different kinds of
emotions and all of that is in service
of kind of like making them a more
rigorously vetted project one that you
know if you're that you know that if
you're not struggling with these kinds
of like a whole multitude of personal
and ethical questions in the process
then then you're not fully embracing
what is most important about the process
which is you know every filmmaker does
have to come to terms with very complex
ideas you know not just can I finish the
film but you know what what does this
film need to be you know and what is the
most truthful representation of this
story and how am i how is the mirror you
know act of trying to document in real
time certain kinds of events altering
the reality of what you know would have
happened and how do i tap into something
innate about my motivations and my
beliefs in order to then create the most
faithful representation of what would
have happened if I did not insert myself
into this situation and you know that's
just the beginning
that's just the tip of the iceberg as
far as you know the kinds of you know
really a complex and overwhelming
questions I think we tussle with